okay you guys and gals are learning a
ton of great information you might not
even realize how much you're learning as
you're going through this video course
but one way to kind of test your
progress is you know go ahead and take
some of the just take one of the
recently-released s80 you know math
practice tests go through this you know
series of videos take another practice
test and you're going to notice that
your score is noticeably improved
there's a lot of things you probably
don't realize that you forgot there's a
lot of little tips and tricks that we're
going through as you go through these
problems a lot of related problems that
are in the same format as they're
presenting them on s80 as well as the
underlying concepts so this is another
video that's going to help you you know
maybe and only on one question on the
s80 but it's important to understand and
it's talking about the strong positive
strong negative weak positive week- and
relatively no correlation in a data set
okay so they're going to give you like a
diagram okay give you a chart and
they're going to ask you you know is
this displaying what type of correlation
now when they talk about correlation
we're looking at the pattern essentially
what we're looking at it the slope ok so
again a strong positive means that it
has a positive slope that's going up to
the right positive slope right and
strong means that the points are very
closely in a straight line okay like so
so that would represent a strong
positive so go ahead and pause the video
see if you can identify which one of
these okay goes with each one of these
so for example a is that strong positive
strong negative weak positive week
netted negative and so on and each one
of these is going to match up with one
of those so go ahead and positive you'll
see if you can match them up and we'll
go through them together but if you look
at letter A it looks like this is
trending down to the right so that's
definitely a negative correlation right
but if we look at say like for example
letter D this was also trending down to
the right okay but notice these points
are very close to being like in a
straight line this is a very strong
negative correlation this is more of a
week negative correlation okay so we've
got strong negative week- now if you
look at letter C it's hard to tell
whether it's either trending up to the
right down to the right we don't know if
it has a positive or negative slope this
one has a relatively
no correlation okay and if you look at B
and E both of these are trending up to
the right it's just that you can see
that B is you know very strong it's like
you know these points you're almost
perfectly in a straight line whereas
this one it's definitely making its way
up to the right it's you know it's hard
exactly to tell you know what the that's
what with that line is but we know it's
definitely trying to the right but I
would say that this is a weak positive
so that's the basic idea is just
understanding correlation so review this
video if you need to otherwise i'll see
you in the next lesson